no flash my suit goes there
wasn't soup together
ah
hey youtubers happy 2017 new flash
footage so let's break it down there is
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
just because that footage is kind of
janky a couple minutes after this
uploads I'll add subtitles to make a
little bit easier but number 10
Caitlin telling Barry he can't do it
alone she's talking abouts avatar mostly
like what's happening right now
but really it's a generality like you
cannot take everyone's problems on by
yourself you need the team team flash so
that's a big u-turn from where she was a
couple episodes ago when she was
becoming killer frost she was the one
that was pushing the team away so the
whole idea here is that team flash is
like the most important thing them
staying together working together so
obviously a big part of the drama the
back half of the season is in people
pushing other people away like just to
borrow flash puns people going rogue
they worked really hard in the first
half of the season to give everybody
their own problems like Cisco's dealing
with the grief from the death of his
brother so Caitlin is becoming killer
frost she has to deal with that even Joe
has his own stuff going on besides his
faint like you know most of his story
revolves around iris and now Wally that
he's on the show but he also has Cecile
so even he has his own stuff going on
so those things start to become really
big and pull people away from the group
and the rest of the group has to come
together to bring them back into the
fold that was kind of what the killer
frost episode was about like Caitlin was
freaking out not telling everyone
keeping secrets and it started to drive
her away from the group but they were
able to bring her back so now she's the
one giving that speech to Barry you
can't do this by yourself
so number 9 next a little bit Barry
voiceover talking to Wally and Joe both
explaining that protecting iris is the
new mission now he's mostly talking to
Wally when he's saying this you have all
these powers but what you need to
remember is is that iris is the mission
so it sounds like while he's telling
iris in the other trailer like about the
future about her dying so we might come
clean and tell Wally but based on the
other footage in the trailer it sounds
like Wally doesn't know and that's
why he's so happy because he'd probably
be super bummed out if he knew his
sister was going to die in the future
too so this is like teacher berry trying
to push wall-e in the direction that he
wants him to go without giving him all
the information which of course is gonna
fail miserably if you've learned
anything from watching arrow it's the
keeping secrets from the group always
blows up in your face so also to loop
this back around to the joke part where
Joe's talking to him about still being
part of his family being his son Barry
again in his grief is like slowly being
driven away from the group although
largely it's his own fault because you
know Wally is like a real big deal this
season so Joe being his biological
father is going into overdrive trying to
make up for lost time
so Barry is feeling like the odd man out
it's driving him further away from the
group Joe is just reminding him in this
footage hey you're part of the family
you're both my sons
number 8 next little bit Wally capturing
plunder in front of what looks like a
group of cheerleaders this footage might
be out of order but it just seems like
he's basking in the glory of being a
newly minted speedster like I just got a
brand new car so I'm gonna tear it up
all over town this is so much fun so it
definitely sounds like he doesn't care
about iris because like Barry's walking
around with all this on his shoulders so
we super bummed out super stressed in
Wally is just riding high because this
is all brand new for him so he's like
Barry back in season 1 right after he
got his power just having the time of
his life just trying to figure it out
just having fun which causes problems
number 7 because he's not like totally
thinking it through dumps his suit like
he runs in dumps his suit in Barry spot
then runs back out pissing Barry off
like hey that's my spot so more friction
in the group you look at Cisco he's like
I don't I don't know what to do this is
awkward Caitlin probably has a similar
look on her face like when you see two
of your other friends start to fight and
you don't really know how to handle it
but just remember this is like the
beginning of the back half of the season
this is all drama that I think will help
catalyze team flash before they're able
to take down sabotage the whole idea is
that you can't defeats avatar by
yourself you need the family but this
stuff happening right now is like the
hurdles that they have to jump through
and it's going to be way bigger than
this it's not like just Wally and just
Barry in just Jay Garrick are going to
be able to defeat
avatar so we'll talk about that in a
second because it involves the other
flashes of the multiverse which is
really a big deal but number six Cisco
and Kid Flash bonding more than Barry
and Cisco bonding so Cisco forgave Barry
for sort of causing flashpoint in
seemingly killing his brother like he
blamed Barry you caused flashpoint my
brother was alive now he's dead so then
over the course of the four night
crossover Cisco caused some of his own
problems so he sort of forgave Barry
like we made the dominators threat that
much worse so now I understand why Barry
did what he did he was trying to make
things better when he actually ended up
making things worse so I don't think
there's any way that Cisco would ever
like just like push Barry out but I do
think that Wally's excitement is sort of
infectious in Barry's being like a huge
bummer right now so sometimes within a
friend group if one of your friends is
being like a super bummer
you just don't pay quite as much
attention to them so I think that's all
that's going on right here but number
five a little bit bigger plunders
robbery that lands him on Team Flash's
radar that's sort of like the big
mission of episode tenth like the big
new villain like hey look is a new flash
rogue so when the surface is just a
simple bank robbery they capture him
they stick him in prison but then you
remember the flash-forward in episode 9
where they give him the name drop in
that news broadcast he's getting ready
to stand trial the reason I think they
included that name drop is just to sort
of give you a book in for like where
this end point is just to like help you
chart it in time mentally this is the
beginning so now you know the beginning
in the end of this new sort of like self
closed time loop that Barry is going to
try and mess with so all the stuff in
between is what he's going to try and
change so remember he's going to try and
go back to the future to change it again
that's going to be like one of the first
things that he tries to do so when we go
back or however many times we go back to
that future point just listen for the
broadcast and see if any of that changes
with the plunder talk so I'll play it
right here this is the initial version
in other legal news the highly
publicized trial of Jared Murillo aka
thunder comes to a close Marilla was
found guilty of grand theft and
aggravated assault after he was caught
by the flash robbing the Central City
Museum earlier this year
so when we go back see if they replay
that and it changes in the way that the
future newspaper that we saw all across
the first couple of seasons changed so
like they brought it back during the
four night crossover like the Time Vault
is back they're just little tricks they
use to help let you know that things
have changed
even if characters on screen don't
necessarily say that so just be looking
for clues when they retread old ground
like coming back to the same point but
somehow things are different just a
little bit so number four another big
WTF iris west walking up to a gun barrel
looking like she's daring this person to
shoot her this doesn't look like plunder
so it looks like it happens somewhere
else in the episode but the promo had
that text that flashes over the screen
powers or no powers the hero lies within
so this is just meant to be a heroic
moment for iris stopping this person
from doing whatever he's doing this
might have something to do with the
plunder bank robbery but plunder usually
works alone so we'll see where it leads
but you you know you have the idea that
she knows that she's going to die how is
she going to choose to face that so
she's gonna have to like find a way to
be a hero even though she doesn't have
powers so they using a lot of metaphors
in these trailers but number three then
Barry tells her we'll face it together
in a different scene which is kind of in
opposition to what they're saying and
the rest of the footage in the trailer
but we know that Barry tells her that
she's going to die so she probably
starts to freak out this is probably him
just trying to reassure her we'll face
it together but you know from the other
footage in the trailer that he's slowly
pushing the team away that's why they
have to remind him we have to do this
together
otherwise the team wouldn't need to have
that conversation with Barry but again
all of this doing things as a family
doing things together is mostly speaking
about the sabotage stuff in the short
term in the broader sense is just the
idea that you know Barry being a god
doesn't need to take all of the world's
problems on by himself so that's one of
the things that he still hasn't really
figured out in the last couple of
seasons he's learned a bunch of new
tricks he's
what not to do when he goes back in time
thanks to Jay Garrick just like joining
him out of the timestream hell no kid
don't you dare try to change the past
again but for like all of season two it
was all about getting faster and faster
like using the Tachyon device that he
could defeat zoom but this season the
big twist is they presented him with the
problem in this saboteur conundrum that
he can't solve by just getting faster
like just getting faster isn't going to
help save iris so that's part of the big
lesson he has to learn but number two
more Caitlin's stuff so they've said
that killer frost is going to be really
big in the back half of the season that
producers like oh yeah we have like a
really big story coming for her
so because her big thing is in trying to
hide her abilities trying to suppress
them it makes sense that in ignoring
that problem it'll eventually become so
bad that she can't ignore it anymore
so we know every time she uses her
powers she becomes a little more killer
frost and you can't reverse it is that
gonna be season four Kayla and she's
just gonna walk around being super
glammed up all the time I would love
that I love the look of killer frost
they changed it a little bit each season
but even if they did want to do that
Harrison wells has a device for masking
your appearance so if she wanted to she
could actually walk around as normal
Caitlin even if she were full-blown
killer frost so there's still a number
of directions they could take this so
you guys can let me know in the comments
do you actually think she'll go
full-blown killer frost again before the
end of the season but the number one big
deal and this is actually a really huge
deal from the comics is is the idea of
the other flashes of the multiverse in
the idea of the larger flash family so
when you're talking about the flash
family you're mostly talking about the
good speedsters on earth one we have
Barry we have Jay Garrick now we have
Wally and Jesse quick so for now they
are the flash family probably pretty
powerful if they were to ever work
together but then you have the idea of
the other flashes of the multiverse and
even though they're not literally family
they all share this sacred bond that
makes them family so what I'm hoping
they get to is it's a bit of a Grant
Morrison twist is that you have this
multiverse Justice League idea now
they're not going to do multiverse
justice league but think about
multiverse team flash working together
to
down savitur because jay garrick as he
tells it like the legend of Savitt are
he just goes around to different worlds
sending heralds and then killing you
know whatever speedster challenges in
there so now that Barry is powerful
enough Sava tar has sensed him through
the Speed Force and is like oh here's a
threat that I need to get rid of so he
sends dr. alchemy and now you have flash
versus avatar so this isn't just
happening on earth 1 this has happened
on countless other Earth's of the
multiverse and because Savitt are exists
in this pure energy state he doesn't
really age so he could just do this for
the rest of time so what do you do when
you have a bunch of flashes that by
themselves are not powerful enough to
take down this super God of speed
well you have to team up multiverse
flash family so this image right here of
them all working together this is from
Grant Morrison's Multiversity but even
if you just look at Jeff John's old
flash rebirth you know towards the end
they all team up they're all running
together you get this image here I think
we're working towards something like
this at the end of the season so let me
know in the comments do you think that
we're going to see a team flash like
flash family vs. Savitt are by the end
of the season because they keep saying
in this trailer that you can't do it by
yourself meaning you have to do it with
the team and what better team is there
then the flash family but what's going
to happen later tonight is I have a new
arrow prometheus video so I'll announce
the flash ring giveaway winner in that
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch the other flash
trailers that I've posted and you can
click here for the arrow trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody
what's that Bob I'll see you guys
tonight